overnight congressional Republicans
clear a hurdle toward a major tax
overhaul early this morning
the Senate approved the bill by a vote
of 51 to 49 last-minute concessions were
made no Democrats voted for the plan the
Senate will have to work with the house
which already passed its version the
merely one and a half trillion dollar
bill is viewed as a major victory for
President Trump and is the largest tax
overhaul in more than three decades it
includes tax cuts for businesses and
high-income people with more modest
breaks for others after the vote
president Trump tweeted we are one step
closer to delivering massive tax cuts
for working families across America look
forward to signing a final bill before
Christmas errol barnett is in our
washington bureau with more aryl good
morning good morning there was an
intense effort to get this bill over the
finish line it required an incredible
amount of behind-the-scenes horse
trading and last-minute handwritten
additions but yes in the end the Senate
succeeded in passing tax reform the yeas
are 51 and the nays are 49 the tax cuts
and Jobs Act as amended is passed it was
almost 2:00 in the morning when vice
president pence announced the final vote
which was largely along party lines this
is a great day for the country it's been
31 years since we've done comprehensive
tax reform but Democrats below the size
of the nearly 500 page legislation and
it's last minute handwritten additions
on the Senate floor when we got the bill
this is what it looked like and online
they're sending around their edits as we
speak can you tell me what that word is
Republicans say the late changes were
necessary to secure votes from skeptical
members and were done through regular
order you complain about process hmm
when you're losing those additions
included a deduction for individual
property taxes capped at $10,000 and
Republicans revive the alternative
minimum tax for high earners it just
came
sort of a bump up of between fiscal
issues retiring Tennessee senator bob
Corker the only Republican to vote no
was turned off by the 1.5 trillion
dollar price tag but other Republicans
argued these cuts will grow the economy
this is what this bill is about
take-home pay more money for the
American people while the corporate tax
rate is being slashed permanently
individual cuts are not set in stone a
family of four for example earning
$75,000 a year would initially get a tax
break averaging $2,200 but Democrats
note those savings would be temporary I
just think the priorities of this tax
bill are all wrong now also included in
this Senate plan were other Republican
goals including a provision to allow
drilling in the Arctic National Wildlife
Refuge in Alaska and a repeal of the
Obamacare mandate that individuals
purchase health insurance Anthony Errol
Barnett in our Washington bureau thanks